Jennsen Wong just officially stated that
the neutering series is going to be six
times faster than the Pascal series at
least for the quarter lineup but will
the performance carry over to the
mainstream platform as well
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so first of all
there's actually a flying that
comparison they're comparing Turing and
Pascal but they should be comparing
Turing and Volta because Volta is the
newest platform and so in reality the
generational gap between current
generation and next generation Turing is
not as big as they make it seen as a
result we are probably not going to be
seen such a big performance upgrade on
the mainstream platform because there
really is no reason for that from an
invidious perspective attend services
all rated top of line graphics card and
there's no competition from anyone else
so it really makes no sense to give away
that much performance at one day and
they would need to however this does not
mean that the eleventh series won't have
a good generational gap over the 10
series this just simply means that it
won't be as big as it may seem from
Nvidia the new Quadro series is using
the RT X naming scheme which can be
attributed to its tenser course and ray
tracing technology and according to
latest rumors that top level 11 or
series or 2,000 series cars the 1170 and
1180 or 2017 and 2018 are also going to
be part of the arctic's series so I may
be seeing ray tracing and tenser course
even in the mainstream platform this
itself would lead to a significant
upgrade over the tensors but there are
other new features coming along with the
11 series as well which will improve
performance one of which is the all but
confirmed with new gddr3 which is
significantly faster than gddr5 X
engineer 5 memory and the new 12
nanometers architecture what performance
upgraded 12 Anna miracle provide over
the 60 nanometer process is something
that we don't know however the 20 meter
process is a noteworthy upgraded
nonetheless and finally we have the
neutering architecture as new technology
part of the 11 R series as well last
generation Nvidia advertised Pascal as
being
times faster than Maxwell and we saw a
to GPU leap forward so last generation
that 1060 was pretty close to 980 this
time we are seeing Nvidia advertising
turing as being six times faster than
Pascal so this time we will probably see
a GPU upgrade of about a one level or a
little bit more than that what I mean by
that if the 1180 will slightly be better
than in 1080i and the 1170 will
precisely be better than a 1080 and so
on and so forth and that is precisely
what the newest rumor suggests according
to the newest rumor the Arctic's 2080 is
supposed to be eight percent faster than
the gtx 980ti
and the architects 2070 is supposed to
be seventeen percent faster than gtx 280
asked for the gtx 2060 that is rumored
to be seven percent slower than gtx 1070
and then gtx 2060 is rumoured to be 18
percent slower than the GTX 1060 so more
or less we are looking at one GPU level
upgrade with the new 11 or series and
this rumour is suggesting normal pricing
and in reality this is just a mainstream
series and NVIDIA isn't stupid they
aren't gonna price it super high we're
gamers can't even afford it
Nvidia already has dedicated series for
those different ranges of GPUs and those
are expensive but this is not that so
really there may be a small premium over
what last generation launched for maybe
up to $50 due to the new gt86 memory but
that's pretty much to max honestly I
believe that Nvidia will stick to the
same pricing scheme as the 10 series so
the RT X 2080 or 1180 should be
launching for $700 just like the GTX 280
so overall curing will not be six times
faster than Pascal at least for the
mainstream platform however the top
level cards may have ray tracing and
tensor cores and they will have a solid
upgrade over ten series for the same
price nonetheless and if you are
struggling to choose between intense
trees and the eleventh series and it's
actually really simple if you want the
newest tech and the best performance and
you are willing to spend a premium for
that and the eleventh series definitely
for you however if you're looking for
the best value out there the 10 series
is probably your best bet finally a lot
of you guys are really annoyed with all
the rumors and leaks around the 11 heard
series when there was really not any
information from Nvidia themselves and
the thing is is that the press
conference or an Nvidia themselves it's
only six days from now
probably even closer by the time that
you guys are watching this video
so really the wait is almost over and we
should be getting official details from
Nvidia themselves really really soon but
that's just what I think what do you
guys think do you guys think the new
1100 series will come with ray-tracing
technology and tons of course make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys liked this video make sure drop
a like and consider subscribing if you'd
like to see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm hari
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]